so we have these two graphs that looks
pretty similar y equals f of X and y is
equal to G of X and what they ask us to
do is write a formula for the function G
in terms of F so let's think about how
to do it and like always pause the video
and see if you can work through it on
your own all right well what I like to
do is I like to focus on this minimum
point because I think that's a that's a
very easy thing to look at because both
of them have that minimum point right
over there and so we could think about
how do we shift F at least it especially
this minimum point how do we shift it to
get to overlapping with G well the first
thing that might jump out at us is that
we would want to shift to the left and
we'd want to shift to the left for so
let me do this in a let me do this in a
new color so I would want to shift to
the left by 4 so we have shifted to the
left by 4 or you could say we shifted by
negative 4 either way you can think
about it and then we need to shift down
so we need a shift we need to go from y
equals 2 to y is equal to negative 5 so
let me do that so let's shift down so we
shift down by 7 or you could say we have
a negative 7 shift so how do you express
G of X if it's a version of f of X that
shifted to the left by 4 and shifted
down by 7 or you could say has a
negative 4 horizontal shift and had a
negative 7 vertical shift well one way
to think about it is G of X G of X is
going to be equal to f of F let me do it
in a little darker color it's going to
be equal to f of X minus your horizontal
shift
all right horizontal shift
so X minus your horizontal shift plus
your vertical shift so plus your
vertical vertical shift well what is our
horizontal shift here
well we're shifting to the left so it
was a negative shift so our horizontal
shift is
negative for now what's our vertical
shift well we went down so our vertical
shift is negative seven so it's negative
seven so there you have it we get G of X
let me do that same color we get G of X
is equal to f of X minus negative 4 or X
plus 4 and then we have plus negative 7
or you could just say minus 7 and we're
done and when I look at things like this
that the negative 7 is is somewhat is
more intuitive to me is that I shifted
it down it makes sense that have a
negative 7 but at first when you work on
these you say hey wait I shift it to the
left
why is it a plus why is it a plus 4 and
the way I think about it is in order to
get the same value out of the function
instead of inputting so if you want to
get the value of f of zero you now have
to put x equals negative 4 in and then
you get that same value you still get to
zero so that's I don't know if that
helps or hurts in in terms of your
understanding but it often helps to try
out some different values for X and
seeing how it actually does shift the
function and if you're just trying to
get your head around this piece the
horizontal shift I recommend you know
not even using this example use an
example that only has a horizontal shift
and will become a little bit more
intuitive and we do we have many videos
that go into much more depth that
explain that let's do another example of
this so here we have we have y is equal
to G of X in purple and y is equal to f
of X in blue and they say given that f
of X is equal to square root of square
root of x plus 4 minus 2 right a G right
expression for G of X in terms of X so
first let me just write an expression
for G of X in terms of f of X we can see
once again it's just a shifted version
of f of X and remember I'll just write
it in general so G of X is going to be
equal to f of X minus your horizontal
shift
plus your vertical shift vertical shift
and so to go from F to G what is your
horizontal shift well your horizontal
shift is if you take this point right
over here which is which should map to
that point once we shift everything your
horizontal shift is to to the left so or
you could say it's a negative two
horizontal shift so that should be
negative two and then what is our
vertical shift
well our vertical shift is we move we go
from y equals negative 2 to y equals 3
so we're shifting v up so this is a
vertical shift of positive 5 so your
vertical shift is 5 so if we just wanted
to write G of X in terms of f of X like
we just did in the previous example it's
we could say G of X is going to be equal
to f of X minus negative 2 which is X
plus 2 and then we have plus 5 but
that's not what they asked us to do they
asked us to write they add whoops asked
us to write an expression for G of X in
terms of X and so here we're actually
going to use the definition of f of X so
let me make it clear we know that f of X
f of X is going to be equal to square
root of x plus 4 minus 2 so given that
and given that what is f of X plus 2
well f of X plus 2 is going to be equal
to everywhere where we see an X we're
going to replace it with an X plus 2
square root of x plus 2 plus 4 minus 2
which is equal to the square root of x
plus 6 minus 2 well that's fair enough
that's just f of X plus 2 now what is f
of X plus 2 plus 5 so f of X plus 2 plus
5 is going to be this thing right over
here plus 5 so it's going to be equal to
square root of x plus 6 minus 2 and now
we're going to add 5
color so plus 5 so plus 5 and so what we
end up with is going to be square root
of x plus 6 minus 2 plus 5 is going to
be plus 3 so that is equal to G of X
just as a reminder what did we do here
first I expressed G of X in terms of f
of X but I say hey to get from f of X to
G of X I shift two to the left two to
the left it's a little counterintuitive
that it's plus two makes it a shift of 2
to the left this was minus 2 would be a
shift of 2 to the right but like I just
said in the previous example it's good
to try out some exes and to see why that
makes sense
and then we shifted 5 up so this was G
of X in terms of f of X but then they
told us what f of X actually is in terms
of X so I said ok well what is f of X
plus 2 f of X plus 2 we substituted X
plus 2 for X and we got this and but G
of X is f of X plus 2 plus 5 so we took
what we figured out f of X plus 2 is and
then we added 5 and that's what G of X
is and then we are all done